over a century ago in the year 1906
about 40 years after the end of the
Civil War Secretary of War William Taft
authorized the construction of a civil
war Monument that would ultimately be
completed and unveiled in the Arlington
National Cemetery in
1914 and there it would stand for 110
years without causing any trouble far
from it in fact the monument was revered
and beloved so much so that for decades
every US president Republican and
Democrat would send a wreath to be laid
at the site even Barack Obama
participated in that
Tradition now before I tell you more
about this Memorial uh including what
it's called let's fast forward to the
current day for 110 years the memorial
was honored by many Americans to most it
was probably unknown it sat there
harming no one creating no problems of
any kind until right now over a century
after The Monument's construction over a
century and a half after the Civil War
was fought it has been decided all of a
sudden that the the memorial must come
down in fact it so urgently must come
down that we're told it's worth
desecrating the hundreds of graves
surrounding it in order to get rid of
the thing Fox news reports quote despite
efforts from a group of Republican
lawmakers a Confederate statue in the
Arlington National Cemetery will be
removed in the coming days the
Confederate statue was part of the push
to remove military installations named
after the Confederacy in the wake of the
summer 2020 black lives matter protest
according to a press release from the
national cemetery the statue will be
removed from the Cemetery by December
22nd the move to remove the statue is in
compliance with the Congressional
mandate to remove all Confederate
memorials by January 1st 20124 the
Congressional mandate passed in 2020
declared that the Department of Defense
must remove all names symbols displays
monuments and paraphernalia that honor
or commemorate the Confederate States of
America by January 1st
2024 an Arlington National Cemetery
spokesperson confirmed to Fox News
digital that safety fencing has been
installed around the confederate
memorial as preparations begin to
deconstruct the memorial which was
erected in
1914 so as part of the moral panic over
the death of a criminal drug addict in
2020 this Monument will be torn down
it's being done at the beest of the
so-called naming commission which was
formed according to the wishes of
Elizabeth Warren with the purpose of
renaming or destroying all monuments or
statues with ties to the feder
Confederacy and now is probably the best
time to tell you the name of the statue
and it is not the Confederate statue
because it's not a statue meant to honor
the Confederacy in fact it is called the
reconciliation Monument it is literally
a monument to
reconciliation it was designed to
symbolize National unity in the wake of
the Civil War and that's not my
interpretation of it okay this is the
express explicit purpose of the monument
it was commissioned specifically for
this reason as a sign that the country
had moved on from the conflict a sign
that we were all countrymen again a sign
of reconciliation hence the name so we
must ask if the monument symbolize
reconciliation then what does its
destruction
symbolize now don't worry you may feel
disgusted and infuriated by this
systematic campaign of desecration this
crusade to destroy our history by
destroying some of our most beautiful
and cherished works of art you may find
it repulsive and insane You may wish
that um everyone involved should be uh
would be arrested and thrown in prison
which is what they deserve and I make
share all those feelings with you but
fear not as the vice chair of the naming
commission explained in a local news
interview they simply know better than
you and and you should trust their
judgment instead of your own
watch and if there's one thing that
commemorates A Confederacy more than
just about anything we've seen it's this
Monument retired Brigadier General Ty
sigil the vice chair of the naming
commission says the message the monument
conveys is clear among the symbols two
figures of enslaved people and and a
Latin quote that translates to the
Victorious cause was pleasing to the
gods but the Lost Cause to KO in a way
it's saying that they were right that
the Confederates were right and the
United States is wrong in 2020 Congress
authorized the commission to review
Confederate assets on military bases
sigil says people should trust the
bipartisan nature of the commission so
we have Republicans Democrats former
military defense intellectuals we're a
very diverse group in every way you
would think that Americans are diverse
and yet we came together uh to do this
Mission there are plenty who oppose the
recommendation including Diane brills
who was visiting from Florida all
history should be recognized and that it
should not be removed but sigil has a
message for them they're still going to
teach the Battle of Chancellorsville at
at West Point and Lee is still going to
win every year but but this is about
commemoration about our values yes you
see a very diverse group establishment
Republicans establishment Democrats
former military defense intellectuals it
is a varied mix of totally
indistinguishable left-wing elitist
bureaucrats it's a diverse group that
consists of swamp creatures other types
of swamp creatures plus some other swamp
creatures and then to mix it up
additional swamp creatures and this
collection of soulless hobgoblins have
simply decided that this beautiful
historically significant Memorial is no
longer consistent with our
values and by our he means his
he has the moral values of a reptile and
commemorating all of those who died 150
years ago in the bloodiest war in our
nation's history does not comport with
his reptilian values and so the memorial
must come down this Christmas season
don't let the government be the Grinch
of your savings right now you can
diversify your savings into physical
precious metals while stockpiling free
silver in your home safe don't miss out
on Birch gold group's most popular
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $5,000 you spend with
Birch gold they'll send you a 1 oce
silver eagle coin for free text Walsh to
9898917350
now is the best time to buy gold from
Birch gold text Walsh to 98 9898 and
claim your eligibility for free silver
on qualifying purchases before December
22nd that's Walsh to 98
9898 the new stopbox Pro is the leader
in Rapid access firearm security that
does not use batteries or Electronics if
you're on the fence about getting one
you can now get one for free the stopbox
pro is the latest Evolution and secure
handgun storage it's proudly made right
here in the USA building on the trusted
foundation of the original stopbox the
pro is larger more robust and even more
versatile but the Real Genius of the
stopbox pro lies in its patented hand
gesture code lock security doesn't mean
inconvenience that's the principle
behind the stopbox pro it's sleak
portable discreet ensuring your fire
armor is safely stowed yet always Within
Reach whether you're at home or on the
go stopbox Bros is offering a buy one
get one free deal on on their new
stopbox Pro on top of that if you use
discount code Matt a checkout you get an
additional 10% off so head on over to
stopbox usa.com right now or click the
link below and Ensure your Firearms are
secure and accessible when it matters
most at stockbox usa.com for their
incredible discount of buy one get one
with an additional 10% off with code mat
now it's worth noting one Minor Detail
here which is um this is against the law
they do not have the legal authority to
tear a monument out of the cemetery just
because they don't personally like it
this violates both federal law and the
legislative mandate that Congress gave
itself when it formed the naming
Commission in 2020 in the first place
You know despite how it may seem these
people don't actually have the legal
authority to just do whatever the hell
they want as long as they can cloak it
in the guise of racial
Equity there are laws in this country
allegedly and they are once again being
thrown to the side with little fanfair
and almost no
protest but somehow the blatant
lawlessness is not the most outrageous
thing here it's hard to say what the
most outrageous thing is as the whole
thing is utterly repugnant and
infuriating um this is indeed a war on
our history it's also a war other things
it's a war on Beauty for one aside from
the historical significance of all the
monuments that they're tearing down
these are also artistic
masterpieces you know I don't know who
coined this term but I I've heard these
statue Toppers uh described as aesthetic
terrorists and there couldn't be a
better description they are indeed
terrorists waging a Jihad against
Beauty but it is also a war on
history people the people conducting
this war they're not honest about it
because they aren't honest about
anything but their agenda could not be
more clear they say that you know they
they aren't erasing history because you
can still read about the history in
books but what they don't tell you is
that first of all they're also in the
process of rewriting the books as you've
heard on this show publishing companies
have hired sensitivity readers to
actually change the content and language
of books in order to make them more
sensitive so so yes you can read about
the Battle of Chancellorsville in books
uh until you can't
anymore but but second even if they left
the books alone history is not supposed
to be contained only in books the whole
point of having historic monuments and
statues and artwork the whole reason why
every civilization in history has
produced these things and revered them
is that it helps people stay connected
to their history in a way that simply
reading about it can't these are
physical reminders of where we came from
and and and and who got us to this
point why do you think ancient societies
without any modern technology spent
decades painstakingly building giant
monuments to their own historical heroes
because they realized that you need to
stay connected to your past and be
reminded of it and have a spirit of
humility and gratitude in the face of
it it's it is that spirit that our
Elites want to
extinguish they want to create a society
full of people who live in a historical
vacuum severed from their past detached
from their future future lingering in a
kind of nihilistic limbo where neither
history nor Legacy matter that's the
goal now this is where it gets a little
confusing though because at the same
time somewhat
paradoxically the people who seek to
sever us from our history also want us
to remain stuck in it now they don't
want us to honor our history or
commemorate it or memorialize it or
learn from it or least of all understand
it but they do want us to retain
historical resentment and guilt
okay that is the one part of our history
that they wish to keep
intact that's how we've end up ended up
in this bizarre situation where people
today in the waning days of the year
2023 somehow act as though the wounds of
the Civil War are fresher for them than
they were for people who lived a hundred
years
ago back then people were ready to be
reconciled they they had put the
resentment to the side they were capable
of seeing the dignity and heroism of men
who fought on both sides they nearly
universally respected both Robert E Lee
and ulys S ulys S
Grant I mean these were people who Who
had who had living relatives who fought
in the War these were people who lost
family members at antium and and
Gettysburg these were people who who had
actual literal physical wounds from the
Civil
War and yet they were somehow able to
recognize the dignity and courage of the
men who died on either side and they
wanted to be unified as a country
again so like they were much more
connected to the Civil War and yet a lot
less upset about it in a certain
way so so how is it that we a century
later have apparently more resentment
and more anger stemming from the event
that the people who lived through the
event didn't even
have our parents didn't fight in this
war our grandparents didn't fight in it
our grandparents parents didn't fight in
it and yet it's our generation that is
apparently still so upset that we can't
stand to see Robert E Le's name on a
building and we can't stand to know that
there are Confederate Graves at
Arlington our grandparents didn't feel
that way but we do how does that make
any
sense well it doesn't make sense it's
total nonsense but it's all part of the
agenda it's not an accident it's a
situation that our leads have
intentionally set up they have
successfully created a society filled
with people who know nothing of their
history do not honor it do not remember
it don't know anything about it and yet
still hang on to its anger and its
hatreds and its
resentments people you know who couldn't
even tell you who was president in
1961 and yet who at the same time act
like they are deeply hurt by things that
happened in
1861 people who could not tell you what
happened 40 years ago and yet who act
wounded by things that happened 400
years
ago people detached from all aspects of
the past except for its grudges which
they cling to
desperately that's the kind of country
the elites wanted to create and they
have and of course in such a country we
cannot have anything called the
reconciliation
Monument because reconciliation is the
very last thing that they
want and that's why it was taken down
and it's why those statue Toppers are
once again with a Vengeance
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there